workshop yesterday was mainly about
geometry and today it's mainly about
algorithms so to begin the exception we
have Ellis Ellis Murray the best I can
do
tell us about her work with genuinely
thank you yes so the purpose of the
circuiting to describe an algorithm so
the main objective is to try to find
shot vectors in shorter lattices in what
your lattices and so what I want to show
you is an element type algorithm that
works for mergers in any number of
shells well as the approximation factor
we get photo shot as victor is roughly
exponential in the rank of the module
and the runtime is complicated but it's
roughly assuming webinar occur it will
be let me go through the definition of
everything and I mean I want first to
start with a bit of motivation so why
are we interested in and schemes using
that uses most of them they use
structural lattices to improve
efficiency so to reduce the size of the
public key and of the size of X so if we
take an example currently we have 12 and
11 of them use structural lattices
so I said to improve efficiency of the
skin and so how how does it improve
let's take just further is the one that
does not choose structure lattices and
then convert with one of the scheme that
you structure analysis and roughly in
terms of size of the public key and
psychotics we gain virtually at least
and in terms of the size
usually helps to get some and so this is
I mean I said structure lattices helps
improve service games in fact if we look
at this candidate is 11 candidates using
circular DC's they all use modular
lattices which is a specific time and
that's the main motivation we are
interested in this Modula this is
because they are used a lot so let me
now define what is a module I so I'm
going to define first module and then I
will tell you how this can be seen as so
value it is an algebraic object and to
leave this in a number field so number
field here for me will be K it's just a
ring of polynomial with rational
coefficients but you know some
polynomial P that is irreducible and in
this ring in this film sorry I have a
ring which is R which is a ring a
polymer with integer coefficients but
and so free module is going to be here
is the definition it's simply the set of
all linear combination of the basis so
this basis lives in the field but the
linear combination should be bring
combination so if you think about K as
being Q and R as being the integer of it
this is just a lattice I mean it's kind
of a generalization of lattice where you
work in a number field and the ring of
integers is X much P so in a sense the
module is kind of a lattice over a ring
R that is not
so this is an algebraic definition
familiar and for crypto we're interested
in module lattices so we want to see
these objects as lattices so we want to
have some geometry on them and for the
moment I've just I mean I have some
algebraic and so we're going to embed
these elements into some real number
field so that we get some geometry on
this object
so how we do that so this is we're going
to consider an embedding that is called
a canonical embedding that map's the kid
k2 situated and so I'm going to map the
polynomial so X and an amount of K is a
polynomial mod p so it's a particular of
degree P minus 1 let's say and I'm going
to map it to a vector where I ever get
this polymer at all the different roots
of P or the complex roots are this gives
me a way to embed the number field into
C to the D and so this gives me some
geometry on the number field now I can
define the roughness of an element as
the sharpness and same thing if I have
victors in K I'm just going to
concatenate all the vectors obtained by
embedding all the coefficients of the
vector and I get a big vector of
dimension K times me this is now
something that lives in the real vector
space so you have some geometry of this
and I can
okay so now what is a module lattice I
take her module as I described
previously and I'm just going to embed
all the vectors of my module into c2 -
okay and this gives me lettuce so it can
be shown that this is ality so here is
the basis if you want and so this is a
lattice of dimension K times B to the K
so I kind of have a duality in modules
either I can see them as vertices over Z
with love dimension K times D or I can
see them as that it is above the ring of
integer R of small dimension K so I have
this two ways to view with your lattices
and just to give you some order of
magnitudes for the schemes that I told
you about usually we want a dimension
ability to be roughly 700 1,000 so quite
loud and the dimension as a module over
K is very small so usually three four
novellas and n so we really have
something very small of there are and
big dimension available and so that's
the duality of the two things and if I I
guess most of you know it's a bkz
algorithm so if we want to try to find
Shopp vectors in that disease or guru
asymptotic idea we can have some
trade-offs between how much time we are
willing to spend and how short is going
to be the vector and so the best rid of
we have some politically is given by D K
T so roughly I mean it's a blue cow
some of the exponent of the exponential
v1 to the N + 0 or 2 to the N 1 - and so
this works for Leticia's RLC depending
on how much time we understand and we
have this specific point here which is
Arabella risen and the rental algorithm
allows us in polynomial time to find the
vector of elytis that is at most 2 to
the N times larger than the shortest big
tolerance and so this my module lattice
has a very large time function so if I
use the led logarithm I'm going to have
an approximation factor 2 to the 700 so
it's going to be but if we could make it
work fala pieces of there are where the
dimension is much smaller then we could
have an approximation factor of much
smaller so that's the main idea of the
main motivation of what I want to try to
show you is can we extend general
algorithm which works for lattices about
integers can we try to exam this to
other rings because if we can we will
get much more approximation factor for
disease so that's really the motivation
and so I'm going to give you so the
answer is no we don't for the moment but
we have been improving the stages the
side of the apse I'm going to show you
this but just let me maybe tell you a
few one because for the moment when I
say Ln n over ah I'm kind of assuming
that I have something I have a notion of
shortness in the number field which is
not obvious so I really said it that we
can see shortness as shortness of the
victor because an element of the number
of it is a vector so I can say that a
short amount of my number field is a
shock victor
so this is a first way to see shortness
in okay but there is another way so here
are two kind of natural ways to define
sharpness
the first one is X is it the size of an
element is going to be the Euclidean
norm of the G element when seen as a
vector
I'm going to call that the Euclidean
norm of the element and the second one
is the algebraic naam and so it's simply
the product of all the apps with values
of all the coefficient of the vector so
these two quantities they have natural
I'm use have nice properties and we are
going to need both of them and just a
remark like if we were over the real and
you have got a real then these two
quantities would be the same one and the
product of the truth value of the code
is the same but when we increase the
dimension we have two ways to generalize
this
and so let me also say one more thing
controlling the Euclidean norm allows me
to control the algebraic number because
if this is more than every coordinate
through this modern so the product
should be smaller the reverse is not
true so if there's a break Nam is small
it could be that one coordinate is super
out and the other one is super small but
the product is still one and the UT and
Nam could be arbitrarily large so this
kind of give me the intuition that it's
better to control this now because it
always implies controlling the other one
so it's usually easier to work with
Euclidean norm rather than algebra
is it easier to control the other one
sufficient I have no example of where it
would be sufficient I mean for some
cryptographic application which we
usually want small is the algebra you
clean no I don't I don't see and also
like what I I'm going to tell you may be
a bit during the turkey is that if we
found out if we want to do ll n so my
objective now is going to be to minimize
yeah what I wanted to say LLL algorithm
I'm going to show you I really need to
control boss so I cannot control only
this one is going to work is it
depending on the steps of the algorithm
sometimes I need to control this one and
sometimes I need to yeah for now and I'm
going to
this implies ups our country
okay so we have a notion of small okay
so we can imagine what is lln now and so
let me tell you a few words about what
is none about generalizing dear LLL
Gotham to number fuels so basically what
we want when we have an area algorithm
is that it outputs a motion vectors and
the trends in polynomial time
oh so here is I've got two columns
quality and runtime and there's a first
result we have about general anything to
number describe an algorithm but there
is no proof that it's going to be
putting in real time and there is no
proof that the output is going to be
small she was more interested into
practice she tried it and it worked
quite well for some small number is that
sort so the same you have you cannot
post propose also aneleanele go sample
or number field but same thing they
couldn't prove anything and for certain
your real number physics can prove that
the runtime is group can be put in an
out but then they have absolutely no
bound on the quality of
you describe it for all number field and
that means so you can define different
options you can doesn't it doesn't make
it efficient for instance yeah so
basically is they have the points they
say okay let's find the closest point in
the ring of integer and reduce with that
okay so more recently there is an
algorithm by humanly where they try to
do a leg for non-residential so that's
number fields that are you trillion for
the algebraic Nam
so something quite interesting here yeah
oh sorry
how about the 2010 Big Brother in Chile
oh yeah so that's yes so that's
something different so that's why I
didn't think we did it so what they do
is see the lattices the modules as that
it is oversee do an LS there and then we
reconstruct the basis of the major but
so I could have probably patted their
out of it then sharpness like it's going
to be exponential in the dimension of LZ
and here I'm really interested in
something exponential only in the rank
of the major but say we fit in this
description with a crappy bound on
quality yes
yes oh yes so something I should say
here is I'm I'm interested in trying to
have something that it takes financial
onions a degree of in the wrong of the
major sorry and that means the dimension
about yes so far normally the unfilled
they could prove runtime but not quality
and they have a different variant of the
algorithm where they can prove quality
but not run time so they cannot either
one of the other but they cannot have
both and except for be quadratic
normally they interfere so now weekly
the n number fields that are quadratic
of credit
and this is here kind of priority to
what I told you that controlling the
algebraic number does not allow you to
control the Euclidean and so what I want
to present today is an algorithm where
we have put and the runtime is I mean by
this symbol is it's going to be put in
the real time but provided we have in
the record that serves so close effect
of problem in the fixed tightly yes what
about the work of can we generalize and
obsess algorithm and technically keep
exactly the same structure but just an
improved and improved the noisiest on
the running time because I don't
understand why you are saying that there
is no bomb on quality in the network
because technically I mean it's very
related to the equations economic region
kingly algorithm because I keep the stem
structure once I have exactly as humanly
but but for normally general normal
clearings in the bubble run time is
nothing but the you have to use the same
bound on quality for origins in the
journal version of not in a business you
don't read the good version so when I
thought there was no proof and nothing
maybe there is a journal version ok and
was to merge the music Neffe asked Emily
and technically else quelled well like a
bound on the quality and the balance and
the polynomial time bounds on the run
time for any non Euclidean number means
if you can have a bound on the two
because I read chemistry this and it's
only for quadratic
maybe we can take this
okay anyway so we have a lot of
restrictions if we want to do LLL
related to Euclidean or not and
sometimes it's not even sufficient I
think I mean depends and so yeah so what
I want to show you is something that
works in any number field and we need so
this is the main drawback we need to
have in a record in general in a fix
that is but this that is only dependent
on graphene not at all in the module in
which we want to measure okay so that's
the plan of the Turk I'm going to dig
more and more into the details so I'm
not going to give you a high level
overview of LLL then I'm going to focus
on ll in dimension 2 which is and then
I'm going to focus on the part of this
algorithm which is European division
which is in London quality is is merely
exponential in the rank over the ring
yes it's putting them I mean quite
you're putting them out in the degree of
the done bucket okay and if you had a
approximate we can arrow a proclamation
sector between approximation factor 2 -
okay
okay so let me describe li let me know
wait that looks a bit like a little
power ring so basically I'm going to see
lln as a combination of twelve reasons
the first one is a rejection that goes
from surging exact so a GPS shoppers for
them so that use anorak resulting SGP in
dimension two and using that serves
gamma GP in dimension K from an
approximation factor that is exponential
in K that's the block and the second
block is the legumes because I gross
algorithm which serves as VP in
dimension to imprison your time so then
if you combine both you get a 2 to the K
approximation factor in dimension that's
what we want to me about so we are going
to have a reduction from gamma is VP in
modules up from 2 to gamma prime ACPD
meters up from k where the approximation
factor gamma prime is exponential in K
and putting the Merlin's a degree in the
first and the second part which is maybe
more complicated one and what I want to
spend some more time on is how do we
serve gamma is appeal in Medusa from 2
so this we achieve it not for exact as
VP but for an approximation factor that
is for the polynomial in the degree of
and this is a heuristic quantum
algorithm and the run time is going to
be as I said oh yes sorry so the numbers
I give other one for secretary drinks
for generic number fields you need to
change the number but basically if you
have a number field with the same
discriminant and the same covering
reduce as secretary the number will be
the same otherwise it should depend on
the discriminant and I'm going to show
you the aristocratic is about the
covering reduce of this fix that is we
assume that there is a cross point for
the target becomes assume that the
lattice we construct here the fix that
is has a small covering radius innocence
okay so as I said this part is the one I
want to focus on but I'm still going to
say first a few words about the first
reduction and the only thing I'm going
to say about the first reduction is so
basically it's going to really mimic how
the lll algorithm works and to mimic it
we need to have some QR factorization
once we have that we can mimic arel
quite easily so the main technicality
here is to define an inner product and
sum to a factorization of an induction
so here is the inner product we are
going to use so we have vectors of
elements in K and we define here ba ba
remember that an element is K is a
vector so I'm just going to take the
conjugate of every coordinate of the
vector I'm going to assume for this term
that this moves in K so this give me
some inner product okay and I can also
define the norm of a K which is a square
root of this so again I take the square
root for the name Python and so this
gives me a way to kind of so I have a
vector element in K and now you have
only one element in K and I can use what
I defined as small foreign element in
case so either I take the Euclidean norm
of this quantity and what it gives me is
the Euclidean norm of a when I explained
it as a very big vector I can take the
algebraic number of this quantity and
what it gives me up to some so Delta K
is something depending on the number
except for that but it gives me the
volume of the modulated span by this
vector so this quantity is norm of a K
captures both the length of the vector
when I expand it and write it as a
vector and the volume of the module
lattice spanned by this vector which are
the two quantity
sorry the square root he has a burst of
the congregation and how the square root
I'm kind of making assumption that it is
Nikkei it's pro it's usually not so the
thing is we're not going to work in K
but in the competitive in K our it's we
just consider the completion with our of
the notion I mean I'm ready to just
seeing my victors in my elements in K as
victors and taking square roots call the
networks and I multiply coordinate wise
I add coordinate wise everything happens
but let's forget about this and just
assume everything lives in KL is the
module lattice spanned by a
okay and so now that I have this in a
product I can define to a factorizations
I'm learning to read the formulas is
that exactly the same as the one you
would have over Cerrillos
you can check but so we can just define
everything as we would have done over R
and we can factor out an matrix B as
something some matrix two times I'm
triangular matrix R and then what we get
I mean the nice properties is that this
is what we were expecting a
multiplication by the matrix q is not
changing the geometry so in a sense we
can always assume that the baby sister
angular because we just multiplied by
some matrix that does not change the
geometry and we get exactly the same so
this is the sunshine is the only thing
that is needed for the reduction from
wrong and then there's our property that
sizzurp so useful in lln when we want to
show that the vector output at the end
is somehow small is the fact that any
vector in the mother should be larger
that at least one of the diagonal
coefficient R and this is still so these
are basically the only two properties we
need and once we have that we can really
mimic the NLL algorithm with this enough
product and everything is going to go
through as a reduction from front to
trunk
so I'm not going to describe how this
works religious is really two
ingredients we need to so now I want to
focus on as the second part which is how
are we going to find subject often would
use a point and let me first describe
the like horse and Rose I'm a pansy
about integers so whoever that is have
dimension two and we are given the basis
of bad vectors and here is the basis so
this is v1 and this is v2 so the first
thing we do is we are going to rotate
the lattice in protected space so that V
1 becomes a rhythm for which I'm the
metric sides means are travelling to
compute the cure factorization so that
we get a transpose so now D 1 is a
resultant and what I'm going to do next
is I'm going to reduce a B to by a
multiple of V 1 to make it as small as
possible and again on the metric side it
means that I'm going to make from a
usually n division of this non diagonal
coefficient by this smaller than 1/2 of
ten-pointer so I get a shot there be 2
and now I swap the two vectors and I
start again so rotation so that v1
becomes a result or you Klien division
of minus 10 by 3 and now I'm good I ever
shot basis so that's like Horace
algorithm and there is two things that
we needed during this address that we
need the rotation so QR factorization
and we need the Euclidean division
essentially that's only so the rotation
we have already seen that how to define
QR factorization in the previous right
so what remains is how are we going to
have a Euclidean division and that's a
half button because you probably know
that in many number fields there is no
Euclidean division so we don't have this
way of reducing between
so let me just give you more details on
why it does not take this so over here
we have which is in fact just a lattice
program it just means the package Weber
Euclidean division simply means that the
covering irreducibly is one-half because
if I take as a target minus V over a
here I can always find a point in V a
distant at most 1/2 and this point is
going to be out so that's nice but now
if I take a number feed an arbitrary
number feed entering our what I usually
get is that most of the target are going
to get this some square root D at least
for cycle to me for this again I'm going
to be a distance quality of any element
of the Ring and so I will that won't be
any ring and amount R such that B plus
RA is more than a row this won't exist
so we cannot happy so the way we circled
on this is by observing that we don't
really need a Euclidean division we can
relax the requirement and we can elope B
to be multiplied by something or so as
long as this something is not too large
so if I go back to my reduction I would
like to reduce be 2 by D 1 but if I
count maybe I can reduce to be 2 by D 1
and I can still get something relatively
small so this multiplicative factor in
front of it which will not be too large
because every time I multiply B 2 I'm
going to go on the vertical axis and
this I cannot compensate by the
difference of V 1 because it's a result
but if it's not too large and if then I
can reduce this to something small then
I'm still going to gain to reduce the
size of my vector so that is the only
requirement that is needed not a
political division but this and now this
x and y is they should exist I mean we
count how many of them exist there
should be some x and y that satisfies
these properties in any number the only
program now that is left is how do we
compute them
should we view this as a basically a CVP
type problem on the principle ideal
as it would miss auricular it's a
regular here you allow you to change the
targets okay I'm trying to okay so we
multiplying the you're also allowed to
multiply the target by oh yeah I'm a lot
communicates a target by something small
and then I so this so this Sunday could
take me to a sample of this yes yes we
can
I mean some modules where the same thing
as follow this is if you have a good
basis of possibilities we can animate
this would be these possibilities no
sets up shop in an independent vector of
any basis of the module then we can get
a good I mean if I said x and y is 0
yeah yeah this one should be none zero
okay you're mentioning earlier that you
could get away with a factor two and the
CVP proximation factor is that / / -
here you want be less than a but could
you compensate for that by allowing more
choices for so this a / - is in fact
going to be much smaller in what we
already do and I'm not sure this to us
anything to do with the approximation
factor we can achieve so the approximate
no it's I mean I'm going to show you the
lattice we consider an approximation
factor to is related to the fact that
so we basically can't construct it's no
it's not related to this the short
answer is this too has nothing to do
okay so let's so I'm going to use the
tool is very useful if is with a log
function and that is defined over K by
simply taking the regulation of the
absolute value of every car the night of
my victor and so this log function has
some nice properties also something
interesting is that if I take the log of
the element of my ring they are all in a
health space and they're Orden
they all have positive coordinate and
this vector 1 which is 1 1 1 1 1 1 so
the sum of all coordinates of my vector
should be positive
and the size of the rug is related to
the size okay so let's try to use this
function here so I would like to express
this in terms of the logs of the
elements the prime is XA plus YB
I mean log of X times a is something
nice so I'm going to replace it by by -
it helps me sure think that it's
naturally XA plus YB that I want but I
just want X a to be close to I be if I
can get exhale as close as super close
to YB then in particular are going to be
smaller than a it's really close nice
things that I want and this I can
express in terms of logs if you think
about the log of a surreal if the log of
two elements are close then the two
elements also have to be close and
that's the same for all log almost so
there is one subtlety which is that if
you remember we take the log of the
third value so different complex number
always the same module which will have
the same logs so we just I lied to you
so we are not going to consider this
flop function but we are also going to
include into the lab user complex
argument of the number after that if
both the complex arguments and the log
of the absolute value are close then the
two complex numbers should be and how
close is this so it's the logs are
smaller than Epsilon roughly the
elements are super other difference
between the dimensions Moroz an epsilon
times the size of the elements which is
good because here I can factor
so I can reexpress everything as I want
truck XA - rugby to be smarter than some
small Epsilon
let's see the fun of the pulley in and
love y smiles and ego flip so let's draw
a picture I never liked a love me and I
want to find log X and log Y so just
look a plus root X is close to love
white person I'm just considering the
first condition problem so let me just
write it slightly differently I'm going
to factor what is the input so logic
are you happy and I want to find log X -
log Y as close as possible
- so I can't look at all the specific
X&Y it's going to be too much so I'm
going to choose the factor base made of
small elements so I'm going to choose
this bunch up there is a thousand log of
smooth ring elements and I'm going to
just look forward path from log a to ask
us which were to love you using only
this factor base and all the elements
which positive coordinates are going to
rule for X and so negative 1 so that's
what I'm going to do and the second
condition now that log Y should not be
too loud simply means that my path if
I'd first but all the positive equations
and then or the negative 1 I don't want
this path to cross sorry so here I get
up four plus three are one it's going to
be ringing in amounts is going to be X
and this one is going - or any elements
between to be wide so this one is going
to be Y and this one is going to be base
whenever I need to take one I with the
political sense it's going in X and
negative
and I don't want to cross this so this I
mean is a picture but it can be
expressed in Tamil for CBP program so
here is the CDP instance my lattice is
going to be so I have an identity block
and on the top of it so these are
vectors I have r1 up to R this square so
I'm going to say describe to make work
and my target is this so let's look at
if I get a vector of entities close to
the target then the first coordinate
here I should have a linear combination
of this that is close to the give her a
so my first condition is met and the
second condition the bottom part of the
lattice and sure that I'm not going to
use too many vectors and so if I don't
use too many vectors I can ensure that
I'm having to cross
and so something to observe here is that
this that is L only depends on the
market so that's essentially the
algorithm the only thing is we don't
know how to solve see between this that
is L so that's where we use and if we
have this Oracle then we get an
algorithm that is quantum put it in real
time because we just compute rugby over
a we solve the dimension of the wires
yeah I'm going to come on from that on
to the next slide let me just mention
one more subtlety that I want ok so
here's the picture was nice but what if
a and B are super far away and I mean
I'm going to need to use a lot of small
vectors so vectors to go from node a to
learn because and so that's in fact not
a program because we have some units and
the units are in edge so I can use them
for free this one they do not make they
do not impress the one axis
I'm never going to cross the proper line
by using them so I can always use them
to get plug a richly close to them so my
lattice is in fact this edges with some
units for free
so this is the algorithm and I mean now
is the Yuri sick because I said okay no
and it's never going to be really
obvious why so maybe and maybe I can try
to say a few things
after I comment on the EurAsEC so
basically what we want so we have said
that isn't the target and there Yuri
sick we make okay sir is there is a
scaling factor because there is two
passing status and we want this top part
to be close up and the second part so we
scaled by something left and the
aristocracy we assume that for any
vector of this form with zero than the
bottom part then the distance of the
victim to the lattice is less than sorry
and so we made some experiments possible
there is more dimensions but will serve
some counting argument where we say that
okay let's assume that I take enough
random subsets some of these vectors I'm
assuming that the top part behaves
random uniformly distributed modulo you
and then the probability can be close to
be aware we can computed so for you
matzo ball of radius epsilon divided by
the volume of you and if I can create
sufficiently many vectors by doing it
just in a combination of this things I
have a good remedy to find one that is
close and so that's where the disk where
comes from that's when we can't we need
to be to have at least that many vectors
to to have sufficiently many such
vectors and to be to hope that one of
them will be sufficiently close
yes see something more about how you
construct the are eyes or like what so
you said something about a factor base
I'm not very assuming the ring is
principal we just pick from the minimum
possible algebraic now okay and this is
where I mean and not necessarily but
that's not what we do in practice we
just Vicki I do such small at the rectum
and this mean easy but okay so any we're
computing the unit if you want to
compute this that is unit the square
root D is there because of the counting
argument to a sufficiently mini vector
and that's also where I mean the more
vectors you have the I'm not going to be
able to explain but basically if we
increase the dimension of the rectus
right so how did it work out in practice
what we have your old Aveda our eyes and
stuff you do TSP the CVP how close where
we from the target so I mean it it was
no so it was relatively easy to start
CDP so we could have lattices of
dimension and it was relatively close to
the target as what we were expecting but
in dimension 8 we can make a distinction
between square d and so it's like with
this technique you could say well let's
say I get a prayer a generator of a
principle ideal and you know you can
shoot units either to get a small one
but then if you're a beta are eyes you
can go maybe below the size of a short
generator and because you'll get
something that's no longer a generator
your ideal that could be bridging the
gap between the actual short vector is
in your principle ideal and and the show
generators so a disappoint like having
to ask me so if that were to be
efficient than you would find shorter
vectors than then yeah Eamonn is the
same division you do not end up in the
ideal but the same techniques we use for
idealized appear so just shift a bit
instead of putting zeroes there but some
Swiss forestry so that you get something
on the positive in the end so that there
is no division but yeah so I mean what
we do is implies an efficient I mean if
it was efficient we would have super
solver for ideal lattices yes
this is this is kneading basically to
solve CVP with the pre process this is a
pre-processing won't help because if we
want a constant approximation factor
even with representing with I mean as
far as we know as far as you know yeah
but back to the mysterious factor - are
you saying that the dimension this d
squared dimension like if I want to if I
want factor to to work the d squared has
to increase
I need more more elements in order to
handle a factor - or like for this fixed
lattice a factor - is okay
okay and so all this counting argument
is ready to Utley oh and bottom are
going to discuss about okay let me just
maybe skip what I didn't say so there
are all there are techniques that we
need to use let me just conclude on what
we get so we get an algorithm that gives
us an approximation factor exponential
and means around comes in module and
quasi putting them in in the degree and
so the runtime again is so what if we
want to run this algorithm in practice
well we need to instantiate this arauco
and if we do that by using a generic see
what we get is very bad so this is the
algorithm we would get compare to be KC
so this is what we can obtain with the
KD and algorithm will give us something
exponential in K so this is absolutely
not to be used by replacing the Oracle
by some and so this brings me to my main
open question which is can we do better
than just instantiating the CVP solver
with generic one can we maybe reduce the
dimension of the lattice and if we could
reduce it to this sort of this and we
would move on to bkz try that so not
beat up it's in the works
and if we couldn't use the structure of
L then we could also hope maybe to get
something better by using the symmetry
of the lattice l and things like that so
it was getting bad
it's just I mean yeah there's no
practical advantage at all the only
thing is that we have to factor out all
the difficulty of serving as if in
Majora's in to just observing CP 150
it's a reduction yeah all Cynthia it's
all sin it's not just a practicality is
also in theory you there is a magical
CVP solvers and maybe some reduction
yeah I'm gonna get the same
approximation in fact eyes and because
you with science so there is that
whereas the one can find it better all
right we reduce the common difficulty to
just one lattice see in one that is so I
mean that's a main open question can we
serve maybe three change the status is
there some efficient way to do that and
just which didn't maybe it's easy maybe
it's impaired and I mean for the moment
and so second open question also I
wanted to mention is can we generalize
this llll to bkz to get all the
trade-offs
so we already have part of the reduction
which was from Ron Cates wrong data this
is Noah and America and but then the
changing path which is going to do
anything of numeration in
[Applause]
thanks for all the questions
let's go offline we have a break until
11:00 so we'll resume in 22 minutes